[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france24 en
colombia hay aproximadamente 17 millones
de venezolanos registrados que dejaron
sus hogares forzados por la crisis
económica social y de seguridad entre
ese fenómeno y la pandemia aumenta la
vulnerabilidad de las poblaciones
desplazadas hoy vamos a hablar de un
proyecto que busca ayudar con el apoyo
de acnur la agencia de naciones unidas
para los refugiados una diseñadora
colombiana y una ilustradora decidieron
recrear el proceso de la migración en
confecciones de mascarillas las telas
fueron trabajadas por mujeres víctimas
de la migración forzada y una parte de
las ganancias por su venta tira a los
resguardos para mujeres en situación de
vulnerabilidad en la ciudad fronteriza
de cúcuta
[Música]
aquí está la historia de una mascarilla
sede con doble objetivo contar los
desafíos de la migración forzada y
proteger tanto a quienes las utilizan
como a quienes serán receptores de
ayudas económicas veamos mascarillas que
cuentan una historia en la frontera
entre colombia y venezuela una decena de
mujeres migrantes venezolanas y
desplazadas colombianas hicieron parte
de un proyecto que retrata su travesía
confeccionaron protectores faciales que
narran en tres etapas el proceso de los
migrantes que forzosamente tuvieron que
dejarlo todo
esta etapa boca en particular
presentación si ven en la imagen
un inmigrante
de su entorno familiar de su casa de su
familia de sus amigos sí
no sé nada ahí está
solo no está integrado están los otros
tapaboca que cuando ella se integra la
historia comienza con la huída y la
desprotección luego a la llegada a
nuevos territorios está un proceso de
integración que nunca es fácil y al
final está la acogida y la
reconstrucción de las comunidades
algo que no
identifica como cuando nosotros salimos
de una parte y nos
y llegamos a otro lugar donde nosotros
vamos a hacer una nueva vida
el emprendimiento tiene el respaldo de
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
y se concretó de la mano de la
diseñadora adriana contreras y de la
ilustradora carolina arias
favorecerla
en cada uno de los contextos donde los
migrantes refugiados y desplazados
por su integración y reconstruir sus
vidas unas 5000 unidades fueron cocidas
y el 30% de las ganancias será donado a
los albergues de la ciudad fronteriza de
cúcuta que atienden a mujeres en
condición de vulnerabilidad muchas de
ellas lactantes o en embarazo y
sobrevivientes de violencia de género
vamos a conversar del tema está con
nosotros en ellas hoy adriana contreras
la diseñadora colombiana basada en
cúcuta colombia que está a cargo de todo
este proyecto y con el saludo quisiera
preguntarle a adriana bienvenida estando
usted en una de las ciudades que es una
de las conexiones más importantes con la
frontera hacia venezuela porque eligió
piezas de rompecabezas y casas para
ilustrar el drama de la migración
forzada
bueno hola buenos días si realmente se
creativa fue que queríamos plasmar de
una forma que hará a el corazón de todas
las personas que vienen estas historias
de los migrantes y refugiados entonces
hay ahí en cada diseño con tres digamos
que son tres diseños tres etapas que
tienen que decir que cuando salen de sus
hogares todos al kibar sin saber para
dónde va a saber que les esperan lluvia
ser frío bueno van solitos a la deriva
como pueden ver en el primer diseño ya
después queríamos con los rompecabezas
que van sueltos pero ya son más que se
van encontrando en el camino y pues ya
había como una fuerza entre todos para
llegar a algún lado hasta que encuentran
en algún momento en este caso pues en
cúcuta que hay varios centros para parar
los migrantes sienten un poquito de
acogida
entonces ya digamos que ese es todo toda
la historia que queríamos plasmar las
en estos tapabocas es la historia de
vida de que tienen que dejar atrás
tantas cosas y las realmente pueden muy
bien recibida estos eso sí estos diseños
como llegó usted a este proyecto porque
emigrantes venezolanos
pues mira el estar acá en cúcuta lo
vuelve a uno muy sensible de ver en los
semáforos de ver por la autopista como
viene la gente es impresionante ver
mujeres con niños bebés y hasta en silla
de ruedas
arrastrando con una cuerda o sea eso
parte el alma verdad
y yo decía algo tenemos que hacer o sea
no podemos ser tan también sensibles y
hoy les tocó a ellos mañana podemos ser
nosotros
y yo siempre he tratado de ponerle la
parte humana a todo entonces no sé tuve
una relación con un gay que quiere moza
quiero hacer algo como podemos ayudar yo
ya había trabajado con ellos la onu en
otro proyecto y dijimos pues vino todo
este tema de la pandemia el uso de
tapabocas entonces dije por ahí porque
por ahí puedo ayudar a poner un granito
de arena y empezamos como a trabajarlo a
analizarlo a sensibilizar
y me hicieron los diseños yo aquí
estampamos todo en las máquinas que yo
tengo de estampación hicimos todo el
proceso cortamos y los mismos digamos de
estas mismas mujeres venezolanas
desplazadas la idea era que ellos se
integrarán en el proyecto entonces todas
estas mujeres fueron las encargadas de
confeccionar y de producir estos
tapabocas y de ahí ha sido pues el dejar
retornar 30 por ciento de todas las
ventas generales retorna nuevamente
al proyecto para para las casas de éstas
de desplazados bueno qué impacto es el
que usted ha visto en estas mujeres y en
estas familias porque son familias
completas de personas que estaban
desplazadas tanto de venezuela también
hay personas desplazadas desde el
interior de colombia y sí también
ellas pues no ellos son muy
entusiasmados porque digamos ven ahí
plasmado su historia su historia de vida
y ven la esperanza a dónde pueden llegar
esto les han generado los ingresos y de
una u otra manera pues han podido
sobrevivir y tener un nivel un poquito
más más seguro no
la idea pues estamos expresando este
proyecto que es muy lindo y quisiéramos
que dependieran casi totalmente de esta
construcción de este trabajo y pues
ellos están muy entusiasmados y siguen
siguen trabajando estamos estamos de la
mano de la mano para seguir trabajando
en esto
mire adriana en países como colombia se
ha difundido la idea de que los
venezolanos llegan a robar a crear focos
de violencia focos de caos a hacer la
vida más difícil para los nacionales sin
embargo datos de migración colombia
dicen que solamente un poco más del 3
por ciento de los delitos tienen de
hecho que ver con los migrantes
venezolanos usted qué opina
viviendo en una ciudad como cúcuta
pues mira desafortunadamente así es ahí
hay personas pero no podemos ajos no
podemos juzgar a todas las personas por
una o sea 100 no puede opacar la un a
una sola entonces lo que hay es que a
esas personas ayudarle a recogerlas o
sea si están dispuestas a cambiar pues
tienen sus necesidades no estoy diciendo
que pues que roban tiene que ser
apoyarse en eso pero pero si podemos o
no no hay que hacer
discriminar a todos los venezolanos por
uno que esté haciendo mal las cosas
bueno y ya para finalizar quiero
preguntarle cómo ha sido la venta de los
tapabocas qué tanta acogida ha tenido en
el tema monetario cómo y dónde se pueden
comprar si alguien que nos está viendo
está interesado en apoyar esta causa
bueno mira ha tenido muy buena acogida
en nosotros empezamos este proyecto como
en septiembre aproximadamente lo estamos
vendiendo por mi página triple-doble
guardiana contreras por instagram
también adriana contreras designer
directamente por acnur ellos tienen unas
no sé no sé
las páginas pero por medio de ellos
también ahí estamos estas son digamos
los medios de cómo estamos vendiendo y
acá yo tengo esta tienda quinas en
cúcuta y se mueve mucho aquí por la
tienda también bueno y ya como última
pregunta como a beneficiar esto a otras
mujeres en situación de vulnerabilidad
cómo van a hacer ustedes que se
direccionen los fondos a los albergues
que atienden a mujeres embarazadas a
mujeres en situaciones de desprotección
pues mira yo yo soy encargadas de todo
el tema de diseño y comercialización a
mí
digamos todos los recursos que entran
nuevamente a
albergues eso sí ya lo manejan ellos yo
no sé cómo los como como las direcciones
yo simplemente digamos el dinero que
entra lo sé lo sé lo doy y ya ellos
tienen pues digamos todo su plan de cómo
tienen que ir
ubicarlos bueno pues esperamos poder
hablar con ustedes más adelante para ver
en qué quedaron esas ayudas y de qué
manera fueron direccionadas gracias a
adriana por estar con nosotros perfecto
muchas gracias
a nuestros televidentes gracias por ver
ellas hoy nos vemos próximamente en
france24
[Música]